et
[Musique]
bon eh bien nous allons reprendre là où
nous en sommes restés pour revenir à
notre histoire
que sont devenus le marin shadoks le cos
moto bus les jbe et la cosmo lune
après avoir quitté la terre c'est pas
très clair ça enfin je vois qu'il vous
reste un film là sur votre bureau vous
pouvez nous le passé allait-on shadoks
ah oui évidemment c'est embêtant oui
mais je peux traduire vous savez j'ai
l'habitude
d'accord la shadoks caravelle fondé
l'espace et la terre peu à peu
disparaissant au bout de cinq à six
semaines on a perçu par le travers le
cav qui dérive
c'était la lune avec les trois
malheureux shadoks abandonné qui
pleurait comme des madeleines dépôt deux
jours après c'était le cos d'autobus et
les shadoks à grosse tête ont repêché et
puis après devinez qui et oui les jbe
ils étaient tombés en panne deux aussi
mais comme le marin shadoks n'avait pas
de rancune et que de toute façon il
avait oublié
il est son valet jbe aussi par dessus le
marché et comme toutes ces aventures là
les avait pas mal fatigué ils décidèrent
les uns et les autres qu'ils iraient en
vacances se repose le lard indique qu'il
connaissait justement une planète exprès
pour ça où il faisait toujours beau et
toujours chaud
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que les shadoks élégie be un
jour il ya très très longtemps prirent
le chemin de la planète vacances et mire
le cap sur le solaire et le marin qui
les avait tous sauvés terminal histoire
sur une de ces vieilles maxime dont il
avait le secret
c'est encore dans la marine qu'il y a le
plus de mal
[Musique]